hello and welcome to Week in Review with
me Jane seka Aisha hazarika and Andrew
Pierce I here to look back at the bigger
stories of the last seven days at what's
being your top stories it has to be
Katherine Granger who's now our most
decorated female Olympian she's absolute
brilliant Andrew well um I rather like
that story about the judge I probably
shouldn't but the judge who gave as good
as she got when the fat racist thug was
sentenced then she used some pretty
colorful language I'll hear more about
both of those in a second but first
let's get a taste of what the week was
all about this week began with commuter
chaos in the capital as southern trains
were disrupted by strikes unions then
announced that Eurostar staff would
follow suit over the peak of the holiday
season it was reported at Cadiz Oh
Sultana one of three teenage girls who
left Britain's join Islamic state in
Syria was believed to have been killed
in an airstrike another week another
inflammatory comment from Donald Trump
this time he was accused of encouraging
gun owners to threaten Hillary Clinton
the Olympics began with some early
success for Great Britain damn good
fellow and his diving partner Tom Daley
were among the medal winners meanwhile
Manchester United broke a world record
by spending an astonishing 89 million
pounds on just one player Paul papa
edsheeran face legal action over his
music for a second time on this occasion
he's accused of using Marvin Gaye's
classic let's get it on and how about
this for a lovely tale a bride was
walked down the aisle by the man who'd
been the recipient of her father's heart
after his organs were donated Jamie
Stevens father was killed ten years ago
his heart helped Arthur Thomas who then
agreed to give the donors daughter away
at her wedding in Pennsylvania
and that's such a lovely story isn't it
we've picked that as our favorite little
stories to talk about of the week it's
quite hard to talk about chicks it makes
me so upset I'd like welling up at it
it's so cute it's like something out of
a film it's so genuinely moving her
sister said the whole family is here now
yeah lovely to think dad said too and
they all touched his heart to defeat its
beauty oh yeah it's actually very nice
fair enough indeed well now let's move
on to Saul serious stories of the weaker
claims that chemical weapons are being
used in Syria's long-running Civil War
both sides denied the doctor say they're
treating victims of gas attacks skies
Middle East correspondent Alex Rossi
reports Aleppo is a place of haunting
darkness rescue workers scrape at the
rubble after another barrage of barrel
bombs shattered the besieged
rebel-controlled eastern side of the
city they take away the metal fragments
for analysis these pieces of metal are
potential evidence of a war crime it's
claimed one of these bombs contain
chlorine gas at the alkyds hospital the
victims struggled to breathe with their
damaged lungs medics claim their
injuries are consistent with exposure to
a chemical attack the regime and the
rebels deny using chemical weapons what
is not in dispute is how conditions
inside the city of worsening the
rebel-controlled East where as many as
300,000 people are living is virtually
under siege surrounded by government
forces
the three hour ceasefire announced by
the russian ministry of defense failed
before it started no aid has arrived
here instead the bombs and shells kept
falling I was raw sir reporting there
why Andhra do you think no one has
stepped in to stop this it's a very
complicated Civil War the Russians have
got involved and they shouldn't off and
who was supposed to be backing other
rebels the good guys we certainly think
we want to oppose a sad but actually a
sad is a ball against Islamic state it's
very complicated do you think it is a
lose-lose situation I should vote for
any of the international community to
get involved here it's very hard for
anyone to get involved I understand
there's a kind of UN resolution that
says if there is sort of humanitarian
efforts it's got to be done by somebody
neutral sort of not somebody who's
actively involved like the Russians that
are involved but I think people do feel
MPs and politicians around the world a
kind of turning a blind eye to it it's
almost like people have got slight
fatigue about what's happening and what
we've just seen in terms of potential
chemical weapon attack that's like a
potential war crime but people just sort
of think well it's hopeless at Syria
nothing can be done and it's like the
whole world has sort of turned its back
on this war and Andrew we also have
heard about Cadiz a Sultana she would
she was one of the yeah three girls that
left bethnal green last year on at
half-term told the parents they were
going off for the day and a day trip and
ended up in Turkey and then into Syria
her family now think she's dead yeah and
we don't know what's out the other two
girls highly likely they're dead too and
I thought desperately sorry for the
families but what were we going to do
with that girl if she tried to come back
to was always going to be difficult it's
a tragedy because they were misled they
were suckered into something they didn't
understand and we understand she was
trying to get back to Britain and she
was caught out in a bombing raid it's
terrible it's a lesson I hope to other
young people in this country are being
radicalized that actually it isn't
paradise over there it's a barbaric
disgusting regime who use and spit out
these kids right let's move on to our
GAF of the week now this has to go to
the German authorities or maybe the
tourist himself a Chinese tourists a
young man who was left and rather
unfortunate situation he's known only as
mr. al apparently tried to report his
wallet
stolen but due to the language barrier
unwittingly signed an asylum application
spent the next 12 days in refugee
shelter 220 miles from where he started
and the Red Cross officials were
slightly suspicious that he was too well
dressed so enlisted the help of a local
Chinese takeaway owner to come and
interpret and he said it i'm a
backpacker i want to go on to France
like a comedy of errors you couldn't
make this up and it's a testament to the
chaos in the refugee system in Germany
brought on by that ridiculous Angela
Merkel can't blame her for this
individual gone I'll try try if you do
say come on down to a million people
they're going to flood in the
authorities are paranoid because they're
damned if they do and they're damned if
they don't so they were being ultra
cautious but like maybe he was just
being very polite maybe cause it was a
backpack yes but you know similar
question a few goats Jeremy learn a bit
of German otherwise you could end up
banged up oh but what seemed to be very
sweet afterwards I mean I think the
whole thing is absolutely horrific it's
like it is again it's like a film it's
unbelievable but pani afterwards he was
very good-natured about it he was yeah
you wouldn't have bad days for
accommodation you budget quite carefully
backpacking don't you have got to see a
jet that you've got very good
photographs so brave don't forget do
send us your nominations if you have a
gap of the week he likes it in here use
the hashtag on Twitter w in our now this
week commuters and holidaymakers have
been left frustrated by industrial
action from rail union's sky senior news
correspondent David bone reports it
seems as though a day doesn't go by this
week without the announcement of another
rail strike Eurostar workers are the
latest group to announce walkouts for
the next two weekends southern rail
staff were in the middle of a five-day
strike until they called it off and
virgin east coast is facing industrial
action too so what is going on railway
expert Christian Walmart says the rail
unions are flexing industrial muscles
are the union's no longer have what the
RMT is doing really is shown that it's
the last bastion of union strength where
you can actually stop a service entirely
by withdrawing labor if you think of
that
1970s oh I do you have the miners strike
power strikes strikes in all kinds of
industry which would have a huge impact
that really doesn't happen anymore on
can't because unions have been weakened
both by technological changes and the
fact that there's a heavy anti-union
legislation the figures point2 waning
trade union power and in turn a severe
drop in the number of workers taking
strike action compared with a peak of 13
million in 1979 there are now only half
that many people in trade unions roughly
one in four of the total workforce and
in the private sector that figure
slipped to around one in seven that
meant just eighty-one thousand workers
went on strike last year compared with
more than 700,000 the year before the
railways might yet be the battleground
for the union movements last stand is
that the case is this the last gasp of
the unions do you think well look I hope
not because I think trade unions should
play an important role in society and
when they work well with businesses they
can often you mean that Nissan is a very
good example where there was very good
industrial relations now the various
kind of em problems here and I I
definitely think people should have the
right to withdraw their labor but i
think the unions have got to think about
the passengers in all of this I mean
look I don't think the train bosses are
at all blameless just look at what's
happening with southern rail I think
they are not handling the situation well
at all but the truth is the workers tend
to not want to go on strike they lose
pay it causes a lot of disturbance for
them they often have you know like
anyone pride in what they do but I think
when the unions keep striking when there
are not talks going on when they don't
try and get a kind of resolution and
this involves the companies as well the
workers lose out but most importantly
the passengers moose loose out that this
strike is a disgrace actually 303
conductors have brought the entire
southern rail network grinding to a halt
in the height of the summer season
gatwick airport is the second major
airport they use that line
so that's welcome to Britain to tori's
for coming from all around the world 303
toys they're objecting because their
work that will change that the
conductors want to be able to control
the doors on sixty percent already of
southern trains are operated that also
operated by the drivers it's a bogus
dispute the sickness rate on this line
has been appalling for weeks and now the
RMT have taken the dispute to Eurostar
because of work-life balance issues for
their employees they don't like working
too early in the morning get another job
then quit crispy now before we go to the
break can you tell me why some Olympians
were green this week although not with
envy I'm sure they know if you know I'm
find out after the break welcome back to
we can review with me Jane secor i'm
joined by aisha hazarika former labour
advisor and comedian and a drew Pearce
consultant editor of the day now I just
loved that segue between labour adviser
and community cuz the two are so linked
I'm sorry you're not the first time
you're at a Labour Party gawping labour
advise a comedian sorry but I think I
slightly better so cheap cheap cheap
cheap gags I am you can get you get it
right for you before the break we are do
you know why some Olympians were green
this week and of course we don't mean
green with envy at gold medal winners
you both got it yeah let's have a look
it is of course because the water in the
diving pool turned from blue to green in
just a matter of hours thus phone call
next to it stay the same color but the
divers were faced with plunging
headfirst into vibrant green water algae
and a lack of water treatment chemicals
were blamed but officials and sister
that it is still safe to go into the
water they've been pumping more chlorine
in apparently which again some of the
competitors have been complaining about
because they say that their eyes and I
was looking very nice no it's not very
appealing at all well at the games
themselves there was success for Great
Britain in gymnastics rowing cycling and
diving but the first athlete who struck
gold was the swimmer Adam PT but he had
to share the headlines with his nan
skies sara had jabig era reports video
ladies
britains proudest Nana better known now
as hashtag Olympic Graham celebrated her
grandson's gold medal with a teapot
photo of revenue company that swimming
sensation Adam PT wasn't always such a
fan of water when you put him in the
bath and EK don't scream blue murder and
but now look at him now he's in that
pool day after day his newfound fame has
brought him international acclaim but
his grand still his biggest fan and
being first one to get a medal / Great
Britain it's a much it's marvelous
achievement and I'm very very proud of
him and a burst with it do you know
fearless oh and bursting with pride for
him big brother James is pleased his
hard work paid off oh I so ecstatic and
overwhelming really and I just can't
still believe they've got a gold in the
Olympics last night mm yeah just savor
whelming just have a olympian in the
family to be honest Adam secured Team
GB's first goal of the games in the
hundred meter breaststroke at 21 years
old he wasn't even born when the last
british man won golden a pool the
olympics back in 1988 he's an
brilliantly hasn't he we've had it had
pretty good first week uh he's great but
grand is just fabulous engine was
quintessentially English tea party
lovely katie was not made a cake in the
tea party I wonder Gino didn't it Janet
on it was hidden summer I bet she had a
sherry no no I bet the gin was in the
teeth yeah generous in the tea Fox yeah
but also she's brilliant she's on
Twitter she saw the Twitter sensation
and I think what's really lovely about
the stories of course you focus on the
Olympians but behind every Olympian is a
family who has put their heart and soul
and finances and yeah I love and care
into sort of financial numbers got put
four o'clock every morning driving in
two hours to Paul yeah in the evening
picking him up financial sacrifices and
that lovely quirky
revelation that he was too terrified to
get in the bar because he didn't like
the water and also at Tom Daley a damn
good fellow again another set of
families who've had to really really
stuff I know that Dan good fellows poor
brother you stuff to sleep in the car in
a sleeping bag was mum was taking him
off to dance tom was a bit upset that
Tom Daley dominated the coverage but I
have to say for newspapers look to get a
swimmer a diver winning a bronze medal
on the front page of any national
newspaper is extraordinary it's because
it's tom daley he is a national treasure
and Katherine Granger she's a bit of a
national treasure this oh she's
absolutely brilliant and I love the fact
she's Scottish as well so I've got like
a slight vested interest in it but
what's great it's brilliant to see you
know she's not old at all but in terms
of sporting kind of Ages I think you
know people saying she's a completely
inspiring figure and she's a woman who's
clearly talented across so many
different sort of strands of her life
she's just amazing you you look at
something you think that is a
high-performing human I'm not fear so
good about myself anymore most decorated
female and yes she's going to be a
writer string story today for a woman of
the year mazing right let's take a look
your paper stories of the weaker and
restarting with you and the death of one
of Britain's wealthiest people well the
Duke of Westminster only 64 a surprise
though he had health issues but what I
think is fascinating he dies leaving a
fortune of nine billion to his 25 year
old son tough for the two older
daughters because the Lord primogeniture
which was changed so that William and
Kate firstborn if they had been a girl
for the monarchy but not saying it's not
for the mirror estos mirror eres dogs
have to put up with this ridiculous
sexist rule but he doesn't pay any
inheritance tax because of some quirk in
the tax rules I have to say that sticks
in my craw when the tory government is
also was setting it up and trick they
will pay somebody's put it in trust yes
nine billion most people would pay about
a third inheritance tax that he's paying
very little and yet the last government
wax people who had a second homes that
people buy a second home putting money
away for their grandchildren ever so the
poor and middle classes get whacked in
their taxes all the time and an old
tough like the Duke of Westminster nine
billion isn't paying his fair share it
isn't right some shocking statistics on
sexual harassment at work what do we
think of them well I'm just saying he
doesn't
leave them thanks for that I know I
think sexual harassment is prevalent in
the workplace I think there is a culture
of n comments and that kind of thing now
I think there is I mean some people are
disputing some of the figures in here
but I think there is there are comments
at work there is cultural stuff but
there is also structural sexual
discrimination which is why is it that
it is only men that seem to get to the
very tops of the professions if you look
at the pay gap all that kind of stuff
how do businesses allow women to come
back once they've had children progress
up the career ladder so I think it's to
glip-2 just sort of brush this study off
and see it doesn't exist I certainly
knew when I was a young woman starting
out in the workplace I suffered sexual
harassment I saw a lot of it often when
you're young you're new in the workplace
you're trying to get on you don't say
anything because why would you you don't
want to be a troublemaker so I think you
can't just dismiss these claims but you
also have to look at the broader
structural issues of where paralyzed
business politics law the media all the
big kind of institutions I'm sure sexual
harassment goes on and it's not right of
course and I wouldn't condone it but I
find our thicker of half of all women
have been sexually abused in the workers
I don't believe it I've been working for
35 years I probably met one or two
people who said that was well rst you're
a man in a senior position of power
always surely one of the things that
often happens with like bullying or
harassment is when you're the junior
person people don't believe you so you
don't speak out about we just fries paid
job have you don't want to be yourself
if your own ice does not mean it doesn't
exist what are the one of the judgments
was very briefly if you say to a woman
that's a really nice frock that can be
seen as sexy harassment well im guilty
then because I'm saying it all the time
it depends how you say that's saying is
we and who you are but anyway repeat
well I'm saying that nice today then I
you sure don't look at my boobs I
alright let's move on judge be praised
for a stinging response too bad she was
said due to jail love this judge
dr. D attracts didn't it yeah Judge
Patricia Lynch let's see this horrible
fat racist who she sent down for being a
horrible fat princes called her a bit of
her and she called him one back and I
know she shouldn't Irvin she's now the
subject some judicial inquiry get over
it the whole country saying judges are
at obscure remote and out of touch and
actually she use language that psycho
actually understood there must be so
many judges over the Earth's have really
wished they'd use this kind of language
and I've always have restrained
themselves kind of sort of silent the
air me anything in the chamber sort of
new culture of the judiciary bit like
kind of a judge judy sort of our judge
window yeah I start giving it back I
think that would make court proceedings
so many more interesting if I would it
may court reporting more fun as well
absent that one more some film because
ago some court cases are film naughty
naughty Cena yeah we would all have
loved to have seen it and Aisha and some
questions for Jules Oliver this is over
and not not so much her quick questions
for her but over who was there when she
gave birth she's had a fifth child a
little boy with and and her em children
within I think her older two were
allowed to cut the umbilical cord and
look I think it obviously like she'd
depend on what you want to do as them as
a family and as a sort of mother wanting
to give birth but there I did read
somewhere where apparently some studies
have been done into like whether if
young children like see childbirth does
it kind of like traumatizing in scarlet
helen is aaron famously said that one of
the reasons she didn't ever want to have
children was when she was really young
she was me to watch a sort of video
about childbirth Nick completely
traumatized what if something had gone
wrong in their touch thank God nothing
did that would mean really traumatic for
their children there are 12 and 14 so
they're not they're not varying the two
older daughters and they there's a time
and a place I don't think I bet it's
ultimately it's ultimately up to the to
the families but I just wonder where is
it gonna win if people gonna be
periscoping though but yeah it's a funny
show why don't we know about it y dejame
elevator works it's a publicity stunt so
I don't have the baby ha ok it's a
publicity stunt for Janos you got a book
to flog what I know you have said it all
right
heartless yeah Lee or lovely news for
them although I probably wouldn't want
that one today no children watching you
having a bad enough having my husband
there alright thanks for taking this to
your papers what about your ups and
downs Andrew was starting with you
you're sending up Iran sharmila she was
the lady who's been on some hunger
strike for 16 years well apparently she
doesn't eat them so to cut out quite
know how she survived so long she's been
fed through a cheap and it was about
corruption in India's she's finally
called it up and she's the longest
serving hunger striker in history so
fair play to her but you do wonder did
she achieved her goals because I suspect
the corruption that she was objecting to
an India we're still going on concoction
of violence yes yeah so we're sending
her up you're sending down though
plastic wrappings and in relation to dog
fertility well apparently dog fertility
is down and they suspect it could be
something to do with the wrappings and
the food so but this could party also
impact on humans and as I have a cat I
want if it impacts on cats fertility
rate we're hip back to my cuts at each
other when you're very young how's her
babies are you gonna lie like the other
kittens to be there well I say no and
I'm not going to witness it either not
least because it would be a miracle
birth because they both been spayed and
quite right okay and we'll send a dog
fertility down Aisha you are sending up
though ed balls oh I have service
finalized myself with excitement about
this this is literally the best thing
that's going to happen to the Libra
price for a long time ed may get more
votes than the live apart although they
look like so ed balls is and the rumors
are have finally been confirmed he is
going to appear on Strictly I think he's
going to be a brilliant contestant I
think he'll do really what I think he'll
really put his heart soul and probably
put his back out like kind of while he
does it and I think pure ivette it's
just gonna be in the audience every week
watching her he's gonna have those
infield you see when you look as
attractive as an woulda come in is to
directors and sequence you're not like
Stan Singh though and I think that's
important you don't seem like deal but
yes long Suzy as and don't use very
enthusiastic about everything he's done
piano lessons just like greed three
piano but I'd love to you Jim with that
line dancing he was terrible cool fe or
sea dog loves a Trier yeah the ascending
EDD balls up for you're sending down
sales we think they're cuddly but they
could have your arm off or not they
cute but they could be potential death
traps basically and people are saying do
not go and send your kids off to sort of
pet seals in the southwest because they
could literally have a horrible horrible
accident it like people used to think
swans were really nice own kind of pet
and actually like swans can kill people
so some steve bassett who's the hub
masterson dieters put up posters and
also it's also been said that they are
Perry like toddlers they will put
anything in their mouths don't let don't
let your small children and your small
two runs hands anywhere near them right
so the day feels down thank you both
very much thank you for that do send us
your nominations using the hashtag W in
our thanks very much for joining us for
our review of the week we'll be back
with much more from next week but for
now it's goodbye from them good bye bye
and it's goodbye from me goodbye